ça reste vrai à quelques heures de noël
car inutile de vous le rappeler nous
sommes agressés par les fêtes et les
réveillons de fin d'année j'ai pensé
qu'il était utile d'avoir un grand chef
comme d'habitude dans notre cuisine donc
dans la vôtre j'ai la joie d'accueillir
jean le grand jour qui nous sûrs peut
pas son nom gens vont mesurer combien 20
96 1 m 87 vous exercez votre immense
talent à quel endroit au 58 rue des
mathurins dans le 8ème à paris voilà
c'est un grand garçon qui est un des
rois d'une spécialité que le monde
entier nous envie et je veux vous dire
laquelle
ici en présentation nous avons des
volailles festives j'ai horreur de ce
nom là parce que je trouve que c'est pas
très très agréable vous savez qu'à noël
on fait toujours des volailles alors
vous avez le chapon c'est un chapon de
l'ardèche
vous aimez le challenge en moi je
château rue chapon ça vaut entre 70 et
75 francs le kilo loire est
incontournable c'est une oie du berry
loi vaut environ ce moins cher 1 45 à 50
francs
on a ici une petite pintade
de challans challans est à côté de
nantes comment la feriez-vous cuir la
pintade sa sortie moi je suis assez
partisan de la cure en cocotte en croque
l'autorité aimerait bien et c'est moins
sec pour les irréductibles vous avez
l'agneau de pauillac alors l'agneau de
pauillac c'est un agneau de lait de la
région de pauillac sa voix un peu cher
quand même là ça vaut 100 65 kg ce n'est
pas malheureusement à la portée de
toutes les bourses
il y a emmitouflés comme un nouveau né
la célèbre poularde de bresse
alors une petite recette gens pour la
poularde mais la couleur de sa peau ce
faire je sais pas moi peut-être cocotte
ou piocher un petit oui pochette existe
bien et puis alors la poularde ça coûte
environ 155 kg ici une dinde fermière de
louer la dinde alors là la dinde c'est
incontournable également il faut la
faire pocher une demi-heure et après
vous la faites rôtir partir voilà ça
coûte environ 45 à 50 francs ce sont les
prix moyens que vous trouverez que chez
tous vos commerçants alors en entrée on
peut sacrifier à l'habituel saumon fumé
ici c'est un saumon fumé artisanale
c'est c'est bon pas trop de citron parce
que ça dénature le goût vous êtes
d'accord et genre on est là pour parler
d'une
denrée qui n'est plus rare mais que vous
maîtrisez parfaitement calé cette denrée
c'était dans le foie gras
alors je vous invite gens à passer dans
notre cuisine suivez moi voilà nous
arrivons sur notre plateau habituel
alors jean
il y avait ici des lobes de foie c'est
des lobes de foie de quel animal des
lobes de foie gras de canard canard vous
préférez le canard un goût de la vie
dure moi je trouve le canard est très
bien et puis il est un peu moins cher
parce que là en espace de quelques
semaines ça vient de prendre 100 francs
le kilo on ne sait pas c'est miraculeux
mais ça se passe tous les ans comme ça
c'est possible ça coûte combien
actuellement actuellement on peut
trouver ça en dans l'ordre entre 400 et
500 kg très bien et vous allez voir
qu'on va vous faire faire des économies
dans pivot charcutier vos traiteur ne
seront pas contents mais fr 3 est la
chaîne qui vous en donne plus les gens
ont fait combien de recettes y en a le
temps on fait de recettes de recettes
avec quels ingrédients avec du sel du
poivre louis du porto ensuite pour le
foie gras chaud j'ai désiré elle oui un
peu de recul un peu de véhicules et
c'est tout et c'est tout voilà alors
pour faire de la terrine
il faut oublier attendre une terrine une
kirin vous l'avez avoue alors un foie
alors un poids assez clair pour combien
de personnes à foix
ça se fait c'est un poids de 500 grammes
on accélère mon cher jean parce que nous
sommes nous en direct et en mange tout
ça à la fin de l'émission
j'ai pas vous parce que vous en doutez
saturé mais donc j'épluche mon fois
voilà il faut éplucher le foie regarder
un on ne triche pas
je pense que rien ne vous échappe et
j'enlève les vaisseaux sanguins
voilà il faut enlever les vaisseaux
sanguins voilà ce c'est tout seul il
faut simplement bien se brosser les
ongles avant que je pensais non mais ne
riez pas vous vous le faites pour à mort
mais c'est pas pour autant que nos amis
téléspectateurs y pense je recoupe voilà
regardez et vous voyez on voit bien les
vaisseaux sanguins alors arrivé riche en
gains on ne veut plus les voir
ce n'est pas une imagerie médicale c'est
une émission consacrée au réveillon de
noël qui je vous le rappelle aura lieu
demain soir
très bien on accélère toujours un tout
petit peu de gens je sais que vous êtes
un grand calme et généreux comme presque
l'un statique mais tant pis l'os avec la
télé z et on n'a pas voulu tricher parce
qu'on va tricher tout à l'heure un tout
petit peu en ce qui concerne le temps de
cuisson mais là on est nerveux pendant
lève les vaisseaux sanguins
c'est très bien l'agent encore voilà
c'est le dernier
voilà c'est des fois de quelle origine
ce sont des fois qu'ils viennent des
landes
ils sont meilleurs que les autres qui
perdent un peu moins la cuisson alors
regardez jean le geste auguste du ca
l'heure alors pourquoi du sel fin parce
que je trouve que ça font plus et ça est
ce mieux pour le foie gras un peu de
moulin à poivre
alors vous êtes de l'école du poivre
blanc ou du poivre noir mais moi je met
les deux
voilà c'est une réponse je crois savoir
que jean legrand et normand donc ceci
explique cela
il met les deux à l'envoyer là je prends
bien les lobes oui et je mets le côté
peau allant de fond de terry à fond la
terrine et non pas à fond les manettes
parce qu'après ailleurs les prenez deux
circuits sont geboers avec des petits
bouts voilà je mets un petit peu de
porto un tout petit peu de porto un
doigt de porto regardez très peu juste
pour parfumer
j'en profite pour vous présenter un
ouvrage qui est indispensable pour les
gens qui sont passionnés par le foie
gras c'est le foie gras par fabienne
labeyrie et gilles lambert gilles
lambert et 1
journaliste qui connaît bien le foie
gras il en mange tous les jours un point
tel qu'il en a attrapé une indigestion
mais dans ce livre magnifiquement
illustré publié aux éditions robert
laffont
vous avez plein de recettes vous l'avez
gens il est très bien vous montrer
il ya de très très belles photos vous
saurez tout tout sur le foie gras pour
étonner vos amis et vos invités de
demain alors mais tout petit peu de
porto un tout petit peu de porto voilà
alors là on va faire une première triche
comme on dit ou comment disait quand
j'étais à l'école voilée cette belle
terrine vous allez la place et 48 heures
au réfrigérateur
miracle de la télévision 48 heures se
sont écoulées
vous êtes bien d'accord normalement
devrait chez michel oliver à l'époque de
l'état la télévision du un petit panneau
là on a pas de panneaux non pas que nous
n'ayons pas les moyens dont 48 heures se
sont écoulées gens je vous confie cette
terrine précieusement et nous allons la
mettre au four alors au four je crois
qu'il ya un tout petit secret on la met
dans un bain-marie rabat marie avec de
l'eau chaude de l'eau chaude le charles
droite impérativement entre 50 et 60
degrés voilà cinquante et soixante
degrés ne vous trompez pas c'est le même
problème que pour les autoroutes ses
limites et si vous mettez 120° vroum il
n'y a plus rien et vous êtes obligés
d'aller acheter votre foie gras chez
votre fournisseur préféré ou chez jean
legrand alors allons-y gens tout petit
problème ça y est les instruments sens
bien avec les jeux vers ici on a fait
tomber un peu d'eau ça arrive mais oui
mais dans ces cas là vous prenez votre
serpillière et vous essuyez genre j'ai
roulé cet internaute à 4 thermostat 4c
quelle température y en a environ entre
130 et 150 degrés pendant 50 minutes
alors attention là j'ai pas tout compris
130 150 degrés mais ça dépend des fours
parce que ça dépend des jours donc pour
l'heure masta 4 vous avez un problème
vous sélectionnez à votre fournisseur de
four habituel vous virer tout
s'arrangera gens on a les moyens
deuxième recette deuxième recette les
escalopes de foie gras de canard chaud
alors escalope de foie gras de canard
chaud alors là on a surchauffé notre
poêle antiadhésive préféré lahondes
énerve également mais vous ne montrez
pas comment on
est-ce que ça on n'y arriverait pas bon
ménage avait taillé deux escalopes des
fois mais pourquoi vous tailler un
billet là c'est un défaut nous non parce
que ceux plus présentable savalli pu lui
traduire
voilà je vais enlever sa part ici on va
même le ranger d'ailleurs se porte on
n'a plus besoin
voilà alors regardez jean poivre d'abord
je seule salle avec un peu de sel fin
m'a dit que le self un genre pénétrer
mieux absolument on retourne les
escalopes on recommence l'opération
doivent recèle fin et là je suis content
ça chauffe alors attendez là on va se
mettre par là ça va être plus facile à
suivre éventuellement parce que ce
plateau est quand même assez encombré je
fais ça alors ici c'est de la fécule de
la fécule de pomme de terre de pomme de
terre c'est pour relire le foie oui et
je trouve que le foie font moins on va
mettre les deux en même temps on veut
faire un petit comme ça un petit
multicouches voilà alors regarder non la
pop sayeh alors jean il ya un tout petit
secret c'est qu'on peut faire cuire ça à
sa convenance
absolument rien c'est toutes les langues
sur notre plateau 1
je vous assure que en plus dont on est
enrhumé sa mégane noté positivement aux
normes ont permis sa faune a regardé sa
faune à la cuisson c'est pour ça que
malgré tout le foie gras reste un
produit cher alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire un deuxième miracle de la
télévision française gens considéraient
que la terrine a cuit tranquillement
combien de temps on rappelle les temps
de cuisson jeudi la 50 minute cinquante
minutes donc imaginer inviter les
spectateurs qu'il s'est écoulé 50
minutes et nous allons sortir avec notre
petit torchon s'il vous plaît parce que
si on se brûle
à quelques heures de noël on n'est pas
dans l'ennui
voilà ça y est
voilà alors normalement cette terrine
il faut un peu l'oublier et la laisser
refroidir un minimum qu'il faut très
souvent la laisser dans la cuisine
environ 2 à 3 heures la température
ambiante deuxième petit secret
deux à trois heures dans la cuisine
regardez on revient sur les escalopes de
foie gras qui cuisent tranquillement
ensuite la pire inouïe au réfrigérateur
oui pendant un minimum de 24 heures très
bien mais si on peut la faire trois ou
quatre jours avant
hélas les parfaits donc si vous avez le
temps en fait les labos social ça va
être juste parce que noël c'est quand
même demain mais si vous pouvez vous
pouvez également plutôt faire cette
recette pour le nouvel an il ya aucun
problème parce que le foie gras reste
valable pour les deux réveillons genre
je vais vous quitter je vous laisse
continuer cette cuisson vous allez nous
servir et je vais rejoindre un monsieur
qui est bien sage qui est patient dans
un décor de rêve
je me régale devant bonjour est ce un
jour régis dos vous êtes le designer de
ce décor de rêve c'est un véritable
décor de noël
on l'a fait exprès parce qu'on a pensé
que c'était la période quand même de
mettre les petits plats dans les grands
mais oui c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi
le décor du palace de l'hôtel de crillon
oui bah on se refuse rien aux périodes
là elle bon c'est un décor qui est
adapté à la fête mais en plus c'est le
dernier palaces français
comment devient le temps designer régis
tôt mais d'abord part parce que je suis
gourmand oui et ça ça demande un oui et
puis je suis un peu spécialisés sur
l'art de la table et
et en ami avec beaucoup de chefs décidé
de travailler les décors en fonction de
leur travail
l'aliment dans l'assiette donc j'ai fait
évoluer l'assiette en fonction du
travail du chef cette décor s'estompe au
fur et à mesure que le décor du chef
augmente alors on a mis les grands
tableaux dans les dents les plus grands
on a une fille en présentation ce sont
des peintres anciens qui sont
actuellement exposées à la galerie de
joker 21 quai voltaire jusqu'au 29
décembre et on a là un homard qui est
absolument merveilleux du pas question
de l'argent entre nous régit je ne sais
pas combien ça coûte mais celui-là c'est
somptueux derrière nous c'est une nature
morte aux fruits qui est sublime
je pense que les caméras de claude de
flandres peuvent vous montrer la beauté
de ses tableaux qui date du xviie siècle
c'est absolument merveilleux alors donc
vous pouvez voir ces merveilles
jusqu'au 29
dix ans jusqu'à la fin de l'année régis
je pense qu'il est grand temps que nous
buvions un tout petit peu pour fêter
noël
c'est formidable de boire dans des
verres aussi aussi faim en fait sont des
verts tailler main que l'on peut trouver
à la boutique du crillon qui est de rue
boissy d'anglas ça c'est un peu de la
publicité mais enfin ce n'est pas à la
portée de toutes les bourses et quand
même sublime
vous pouvez la trouver la boutique
qu'adrien 12 boulevard à 7 boulevard
raspail
si vous n'avez pas tous noté vous tapez
notre codes minitel 36 15 pick 3 vous
aurez la recette de jean legrand
si vous n'avez pas tous noté vous pouvez
lire le livre de fabienne labeyrie de
gilles lambert aux éditions robert
laffont
vous allez chez jean legrand il sera
ravi de vous vendre des terrines
elles sont parmi les moins chers de
paris j'en profite pour le préciser
et puis si on ne sait jamais vous voulez
une table de fête vous pouvez aller voir
régis d'eau boulevard raspail il sera
heureux au moins de vous présenter
toutes ses créations
ce que vous n'avez pas que sa régie non
non il ya plein d'autres choses sublimes
voilà nous sommes servis par le maître
en personne jean merci infiniment
régis il ya un petit peu de vin gris un
petit peu de pain grillé gens c'est noël
il est normal que le cuistot qui nous
asservit prenne ma place et s'asseoir
voilà régis jean legrand alors vous tvo
production si ça ne vous plaît pas vous
n'avez qu'à vous en prendre à vous même
on a fait tout ça en direct devant vous
et c'était vraiment très simples gens
vous goûtez si je vous dis quand c'est
bon
[Musique]
y'a pas meilleur et nous vous souhaitons
un très joyeux noël